des images de même fils qui ébranle une
fois de plus la confiance de l'Amérique
envers les forces de l'ordre on y voit
tarin et cause intercepté en raison de
la conduite soit disant imprudente de
son véhicule pour une raison inconnue
l'arrestation du 7 janvier des génères
en l'espace d'une quinzaine de minutes
l'homme de 29 ans et menotté aspergé de
poivre et roué de coup par 5 policiers
il meurt des suites de ses blessures
trois jours plus tard
les dimensions a poussé des milliers
d'Américains dans les rues des
manifestations pacifiques à la demande
de la mère de tyrin école
[Musique]
parmi les défaillances le chef de police
des notes que les caméras d'intervention
sont activées trop tard pour comprendre
ce qui a déclenché une telle agressivité
les 5 policiers impliqués sont
maintenant accusés de meurtre au
deuxième degré et d'enlèvement deux
autres ont été suspendus certains
faisaient partie de l'unité scorpion
mandatée depuis 2021 pour combattre les
crimes violents à Memphis l'unité a
finalement été dissoute tel que demandée
par la famille Nicole
[Musique]
les organisations de défense des droits
réclament haut et fort une réforme
fédérale des corps policiers en
attendant des élus du Tennessee veulent
adopter des lois pour obliger les
policiers à se soumettre à des
évaluations psychologiques annuelles
une manière de prévenir d'autres bavures
policières
story la confiance des Américains ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal